[Musique]
nous poursuivons les travaux de notre
commission d'enquête par l'audition du
Professeur Alain Fischer que je remercie
de cette mobilisée aujourd'hui
si nous vous connaissons tout en tous en
tant que président du Conseil
d'orientation de la stratégie vaccinale
au plus fort de la pandémie de la
covid-19 nous avons eu l'occasion de
vous avoir plusieurs fois en édition
c'est le président le président de
l'Académie des Sciences et professeurs
honoraires du Collège de France
spécialiste en immunologie et
pédiatrique que nous entendons
aujourd'hui
j'ajoute que vous êtes l'auteur au nom
de la Fondation Terra Nova d'un rapport
rendu public le 18 janvier dernier sur
la recherche médicale en France et par
ailleurs chroniqueur Aliexpress
notre commission d'enquête a un double
objet les pénuries de médicaments mais
également les choix de l'industrie
pharmaceutique française les deux étant
liés et vous avez bien compris que le
débat entre médicament mature et
innovation était très intriqués
ces deux enjeux nous ont naturellement
conduit examiné le modèle économique de
l'industrie du médicament et en
particulier la place qui occupe
l'innovation sont financement et la
prise en charge des thérapies de plus en
plus coûteuse qui en sont issues c'est à
ce titre monsieur le Président que nous
souhaitons disposer de votre expertise
en effet vous aviez alerté sur le
caractère exorbitant du prix demandé par
les laboratoires pour les médicaments
relevant des thérapies cellulaires
tissulaires cellulaire et génétique
avant la prise de conscience générale de
cette problématique dès 2020 vous aviez
démontré que l'argument mise en avant
par les laboratoires des vies
transformés par les traitements
administrés en une seule fois au prix
sans commune mesure avec ce pratiquée
jusqu'à là ne tenait pas ne serait-ce
que compte tenu du manque de recul sur
l'efficacité de ces traitements qui ne
dépassent pas trois à cinq
vous appeliez alors je cite à une vision
plus équilibrée de l'intérêt général et
d'un retour raisonnable sur
investissement qui permettent la
poursuite de l'innovation vous pourrez
nous préciser ce que vous entendez par
cette déclaration que les dernières
années n'ont fait que confirmer en
matière d'innovation vous avez également
alerté sur l'état selon vous
préoccupants de la recherche française
nous serons attentifs à vos
préconisations pour remédier à cette
situation d'autant plus préjudiciable
que comme vous avez eu l'occasion de le
dire l'innovation nécessitant en amont
une recherche active et efficace faute
de quoi la France risque d'encourager la
production de biomédicaments sont
disposés de la capacité à inventer les
médicaments de demain enfin pour en
revenir aux pénuries de médicaments
proprement dites je soulignerai que dès
septembre 2022 vous alertiez sur le
risque d'une épidémie de grippe en
France concomitante avec un rebond de
l'épidémie de covid-19 l'histoire vous a
malheureusement donné raison et
l'épidémie de bronchiolite que j'allais
ajouter dans mon propos n'a fait
qu'accent UER l'impact sanitaire de
cette situation à l'origine de pénurie
qui ont d'autant plus inquiétée
l'ensemble des Français quel toucher des
produits d'usage courant comme
l'amoxicilline ou le paracétamol
nous serons
par conséquent attentif à ce que vous
pourrez nous dire sur la promotion de la
politique de santé publique que vous
appelez de vos vœux notamment s'agissant
de la prévention sur l'ensemble de ces
sujets monsieur présent je vais vous
céder la parole pour un bref propos un
productif puis madame Laurence Cohen
rapporteur de notre commission d'enquête
vous posera une première série de
questions je précise également que cette
audition est diffusée en direct sur le
site internet du Sénat et qu'elle fera
l'objet d'un compte rendu publié avant
de vous donner la parole je vous
rappelle qu'un faux témoignage est
vraiment notre commission d'enquête et
passive des peines prévues aux articles
quatre en tant que 13 434-14 et 434-15
du code pénal je vous invite à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité en levant la main droite et en
disant que je le jure je vous remercie
par ailleurs de nous faire part de vos
éventuels liens d'intérêt monsieur
Fischer
je le jure mais peut-être qu'il faut
juste de quoi qu'est-ce que je jure
toute la vérité
c'est bon
de votre invitation je tiens à préciser
à vous avez mis ce qui est exact je suis
aujourd'hui Président lacrimination je
ne parle pas au nom de l'Académie des
Sciences je parle à titre personnel j'en
sais important de même si l'Académie des
sciences comme d'autres académies
évidemment s'intéressent à ces questions
en termes de liens conflit d'intérêt
j'ai pas j'ai dans si vous regardez mes
dpi qui est public et j'ai été impliqué
dans la création d'une startup mais sans
intérêt personnel et qui émane de
l'Institut je travaille encore même si
je suis censé être retraité s'appelle
institut imagine qui est sur le site de
l'hôpital Necker enfant malade et voilà
quoi en terme privé c'est tout
sur l'aspect de la pénurie médicaments
je n'ai guère de compétences dans ce
domaine donc j'en parlerai pas même si
je suis conscient qu'il y a un lien
d'ailleurs vous avez vous aviez évoqué
la question à l'instant avec les
personnes de Sanofi je me sens un peu
plus compétent sur la problématique de
l'accessibilité des médicaments
innovants et puis on peut à partir de là
selon vos souhaits continuer sur les
aspects recherche santé publique que
vous avez évoqué il y a un instant donc
pour pas être trop long vous le savez je
pense que vous l'avez entendu
multiplement il faut commencer par les
bonnes nouvelles les bonnes nouvelles
c'est qu'il depuis un certain nombre
d'années on observe et ça ne se dément
pas des avancées la recherche médicale
qui sont très significatives en termes
de thérapeutique que ce soit
thérapeutique classique du médicament
chimiques que ce soit des biothérapies
qui représente aujourd'hui 40% des
médicaments mis sur le marché ou des
thérapies cellulaires et surtout
géniques deux trois exemples pour
illustrer mon propos pour les
médicaments je vais prendre l'exemple de
la mucoviscidose donc une maladie rare
mais pas si rare que ça
[Musique]
donc ça ce sont les bonnes nouvelles
c'est qu'il y a vraiment de la vraie
avancée médicale sont pas des
médicaments MiTo sont des médicaments
transformant j'y reviendrai et puis il y
a beaucoup de perspectives les
recherches en cours dans tous ces
domaines sont florissantes
même s'il est toujours très difficile de
faire des prédictions mais il est on ne
peut pas imaginer une seconde que ce que
les avancées ne s'arrêtent en subitement
s'arrêter en 2023 je pense que les
années qui vont venir verront mis sur le
marché au moins dans certains domaines
il reste des creux terribles comme les
maladies du cerveau ou malheureusement
on est nettement moins avancé mais les
psychiatriques et d'autres enfin bref
mais enfin globalement il y a notamment
le cancer mais pas que des progrès très
significat donc ça ce sont les bonnes
nouvelles mais moins bonnes nouvelles
c'est le prix de ces médicaments si je
reprends les exemples que je vais citer
il y a un instant la mucoviscidose donc
cette trithérapie autant qu'on puisse le
savoir ce qu'on y reviendra mais comme
vous savez les prix ne sont pas connus
publiquement en France mais enfin on
peut quand même avoir un certain nombre
d'informations mais le traitement par an
pour un malade la mucovisc c'est 200000
euros et c'est à vie c'est pas une fois
c'est pas comme une thérapie génique
éventuellement les différents
traitements par Anticor monoclonaux dans
les cancers et autres
monoclonaute du cancer les ce qu'on
appelle les check point inhibiteurs qui
sont beaucoup utilisés aujourd'hui c'est
de l'ordre de 50 000 à 100000 € par curé
par malade pour les maladies communes
c'est plus seulement entre guillemets 10
20 000 euros les traits les nouveaux
traitements de l'hémophilie sont autour
de 100000 euros par an et par malade les
traitements les thérapies géniques les
fameuses quartissaient 400 000 euros par
malade
qui viennent s'ajouter à d'autres
traitements c'est les malades qui
reçoivent des quartiers s'ils ont
souvent une grève de moelle osseuse
après etc etc etc les nouveaux
traitements de l'hémophilie ont été
commercialisés aux États-Unis au prix de
3 millions de dollars par malades la
myotofie spinale est vendue le produit
est vendu en France je crois que ce
chiffre est exact encore une fois il
peut y avoir comme il y a les rabais
c'est pas tous mais je pense que le
chiffre est exact parce que je l'ai de
l'Assistance publique 1,9 millions
d'euros bon je pourrais continuer je
vais pas faire une longue liste mais
enfin voilà donc ces produits coûte
extrêmement cher ce sont les produits
les plus chers aujourd'hui de tous les
médicaments et de loin et donc
ces prix sont aujourd'hui totalement
déconnectés
mais c'est revendiquer le par
l'industrie je vais revenir des coûts de
Recherche Développement production
marketing c'est déconnecté totalement
déconnecté pour alors la justification
de la déconnexion c'est de dire que ces
médicaments sont sophistiqués
leur coûts développement coûte plus cher
que ce que le médicament ou autre ça
peut être vrai mais c'est pas dans une
dimension fantastiquement plus élevée et
surtout parce que ces traitements sont
pour ceux qui sont one shot une seule
fois pourraient être on passe d'une
maladie chronique grave voire mortelle à
une maladie guéri et donc c'est
évidemment un argument qui compte qu'il
faut prendre en compte c'est la valeur
transformative si le mot est correct
transformatif de ces traitements alors
c'est pas toujours le cas on va revenir
mais enfin ce sont les arguments mis en
avant par l'industrie pharmaceutique par
spécialement française c'est évidemment
totalement mondial si on prend ces
arguments il y a aussi le que souvent
sont des maladies rares à petits marchés
si on reprend ses dons qui peuvent
nécessiter des coûts plus élevés des
prix plus élevés
concernant le l'aspect sophistiqué plus
élevé développement oui mais en fait la
quasi-totalité de ces médicaments ont
été en fait développés par la recherche
académique ou fortement proche de la
recherche académique par exemple
l'association de parents on peut penser
à l'AFM pour la myopie spinale et
qu'ensuite c'est produire ont été
rachetés par l'industrie mais à des
coûts
ou par les revenus qui peuvent qui
reviennent à mon académique ou
associatif qui sont très loin de des
prix on peut évoquer des chiffres si
vous le souhaitez
le fait que les marchés petite taille
des marchés c'est parfois vrai pas
toujours il y a aucune corrélation entre
la taille du marché le prix des
médicaments si on regarde en détail pour
ces médicaments surtout le point
essentiel donc c'est le caractère
transformatif ou non de ces traitements
donc encore une fois certains sont
transformatifs mais sont avis si je
prends l'exemple de la mucoviscidose ou
certains traitements de l'hémophilie que
sur le temps même pour ceux qui sont
vraiment transformatifs a priorité
rapide génique on a des rares recul un
peu plus important maintenant on est à 7
8 10 ans pour certaines maladies dans
quelques cas il y a des chances que ce
soit définitif mais c'est pas sûr que ça
soit définitif dans tous les cas loin de
là et que par ailleurs notamment pour
les maladies neuromusculaires la cure
peut être incomplète qui persiste des
manifestations cliniques voire on peut
imaginer même l'apparition de
manifestations clinique était pas connue
mais qui apparaissent parce que les
malades survivent donc imaginez que
c'est que ce soit totalement
transformatif et qu'on s'en sort une
personne avec une maladie grave Issime
en une personne qui a une vie normale ça
peut être vrai dans quelques cas mais
c'est pas la majorité et puis il y a des
incertitudes sur le long terme
évidemment pour tous ces patients et
j'ajouterai peut-être pour moi le point
le plus important même si
l'argumentaire de l'industrie était
totalement jugeant il est pas totalement
faux il faut le prendre en compte mais
si les imaginons qu'ils soient
totalement juste et qui permettent pour
un certain nombre de situations moi
d'abord avoir évidemment des gains de
vie et de qualité de vie ce qui est
très important et même faire gagner de
temps en temps de l'argent parce que un
traitement one shot va coûter moins cher
qu'un traitement à vie si on prend de
l'hémophilie replanocytose encore que il
y a une étude qui vient de sortir aux
États-Unis qui montre que c'est pas si
évident pour la Dripper aussitôt mais au
moins pour l'hémophilie c'est à peu près
juste donc il y a un gain indéniable
mais la question qui peut se poser après
chacun est libre d'y répondre est-ce que
ce gain doit aller uniquement à
l'industriel qui a fait le produit à la
société enfin quelle est l'équilibre il
me semble que la moindre des choses
c'est de considérer que le partage du
gain doit être équilibré je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il n'est pas équilibré
voilà
à vrai dire si on regarde enfin je
répète ce qui a été écrit par beaucoup
si on regarde le comment ces prix sont
fixés ils sont surtout fixés et au plus
haut possible accepter comme pas
toujours le cas mais accepté par les
autorités réglementaires quand il y en a
c'est en Europe et pas aux États-Unis
malheureusement je reviendrai là-dessus
parce que je pense que prennent des
états des États-Unis excusez-moi pèse
très lourd les conséquences de cette de
cette situation c'est de temps en temps
ces produits sont pas mis à disposition
soit parce qu'ils sont refusés par les
autorités réglementaires comme trop cher
soit comme l'Europe est plus dure que
les États-Unis les industriels se
retirent du marché européen c'était le
cas par homme de la société Bluebird qui
commercialise certains médicaments
thérapies géniques qui ne vend son
produit qu'aux États-Unis
donc tout ceci n'est pas il y a même des
domaines mon domaine celui des défis
immunitaires reditaires où il se trouve
malheureusement qu'une société à un
moment donné s'est retrouvée en quasi
monopole des trois médicaments
disponibles et à la décida tout arrêter
et c'est moi que c'était pas assez
rentable et donc il n'y a plus de
médicaments disponible aujourd'hui pour
ces maladies alors il y a des
alternatives graphe le moelle osseuse
etc c'est pas une catastrophe
heureusement pour les malades moi c'est
comme c'est pas une bonne nouvelle c'est
beaucoup de jeux à titre personnel qui
était beaucoup impliqué dans ces travaux
de recherche et à 20 ans encore plus
récemment c'est une certaine frustration
et si on réfléchit maintenant en se
projetant à l'avenir il y a une étude
qui est assez intéressante d'un institut
de recherche économique américain qui a
la SR qui est évidemment indépendant
l'industrie pharmaceutique ils ont fait
une étude publiée à maintenant 5-6 ans
mais à mon avis qui reste complètement
juste ils avaient le calcul que si on
mettait au point on est content que les
thérapies géniques dans le pain de
toutes les autres thérapeutiques une
thérapie génique
et donc première objectif
l'accessibilité aux patients français si
on reste dans le pour de chez nous et
deuxièmement il faut maintenir
évidemment le savoir-faire l'incitation
et le développement par l'industrie de
médicaments on a besoin d'industrie donc
il faut injuste simplement il faut un
équilibre mon point de vue aujourd'hui
on n'est pas à l'équilibre le curseur
est allé progressivement trop loin en
faveur des bénéfices d'industrie
pharmaceutiques je reviendrai et ceci
est difficile il faut pas se faire
d'illusions même si on peut évoquer
quelques points je pense que évidemment
le marché du médicament il est mondial
et comme vous le savez certainement il y
a pratiquement pas de régulation des
prix aux États-Unis un tout petit peu
mais il y a une tentative actuelle de
mais c'est par rapport à ce qui se passe
en Europe c'est ridicule mais si on
regarde c'est assez intéressant ce que
dans les journaux américains qui sont
aujourd'hui pas avare de papiers sur
cette question nous avons le New York
Journal of Medicine publie les articles
l'un après l'autre sur cette question
mais qui considère presque l'Europe
comme une situation
idyllique enfin j'exagère alors pourtant
elle ne l'est pas par rapport aux
États-Unis c'est évidemment moins il
faut savoir que le prix des médicaments
aux États-Unis c'est en moyenne 2 à 3
fois le prix en Europe et c'est un
problème pour l'Europe parce que du coup
l'industrie a un levier de pression en
disant comme l'a fait faible la société
blueborne même si le marché européen est
très important à la limite je vais
vendre mes médicaments aux États-Unis en
tous les cas et le prix Les prix très
élevé au met des médicaments aux
Etats-Unis tirent vers le haut les prix
même chez nous et évidemment nous
n'avons aucun moyen de pression pour
intervenir sur les prix des médicaments
aux États-Unis si ce n'est espérer que
les choses finissent par évoluer il y a
une prise de conscience il y a beaucoup
de papiers la communauté médicale est
assez clairement au fait de cela il y a
je sais que au sein au moins du Parti
démocrate aux États-Unis il y a des une
volonté d'avancer mais aujourd'hui c'est
pas le cas donc c'est un problème
sérieux peut-être le problème le plus
difficile et qui nous échappe qui vous
échappe et encore plus à moi donc les
quelques points néanmoins qu'on peut
essayer d'avancer
toute la négociation des prix Les prix
tout est complètement opaque
c'est la volonté que je comprends un peu
mais qui ne finit je pense n'est pas
bonne du CEPS ou comme vous savez
sûrement même mieux que moi les on ne
connaît pas les prix négociés il y a des
rabais etc etc mais je pense que c'est
pas une bonne situation
ainsi d'amment l'OMS conduit une
résolution en mai 2009 mais
malheureusement qui n'est pas qui n'est
simplement comme on dit consulter afin
de c'est pas de consultatif mais enfin
qui ne s'impose pas aux états de en
faveur de la transparence des systèmes
de fixation des prix et des prix et je
crois qu'il finit la transparence enfin
vu du côté public la transparence
serait quand même mieux que l'opacité
l'opacité permet d'obtenir des rabais je
crois que dans certains cas ils sont
vraiment importants néanmoins
dans le système d'opacité
les négociateurs publics sont pas en
situation favorable parce que
l'industrie elle part des finitions il
connaît les prix de vente dans tous les
pays
[Musique]
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure qu'il faut
prendre en compte mais qu'il ne peut pas
être l'élément unique et qui fait qui
crée ce déséquilibre à mon avis qui
n'est pas bon il y a un troisième point
je voudrais évoquer c'est je l'ai déjà
mentionné brièvement c'est tenir compte
de l'apport académique donc encore une
fois la plupart de ces médicaments
viennent du monde académique et le
retour sur investissement vers le monde
académique est très insuffisant
académique au sens large j'ai ajouté
l'exemple de la myotrophie spinale et
l'AFM et parlant et je crois que la fn
touche 15 millions d'euros par an
royalties pour un médicament qui est
vendu 1,9 millions d'euros par malade et
qui rappelant des bénéfices à nos
artistes colossal donc là il y a un
déséquilibre est une certaine façon nous
citoyens contribua nous payons deux fois
on paye la recherche
académique et on repeint le médicament
très cher
donc ceci n'est pas un avis pas
satisfaisant quatrième point c'est au
moins envisagé on peut pas envisager de
négociation des prix mondiales ça n'a
pas de sens mais il y a quand même un il
me semble un niveau où on pourrait
réfléchir c'est la Communauté européenne
aujourd'hui quand vous savez les chaque
pays enfin pas tout à fait chaque pays
mais la France négocie toute seule
certains petits pays entre guillemets
par la taille se sont au niveau européen
se sont mis ensemble je crois qu'il y a
deux sous-ensembles ou inégocient
ensemble parce qu'ils sentent un tout
petit peu moins seul et peut-être un peu
moins faible mais pourquoi ne pas
imaginer que la même façon qu'il y a une
agence européenne du médicament pour la
validation et la mission le marché et
ben que il y a une extension disons de
l'Agence européenne du médicament qui
négocie les prix quitte ce qui est des
péréquations pour les pays moins riches
après tout il y a un exemple où c'est un
marché et ça même très bien marché c'est
des vaccins anti sarcope 2 qui ont été
achetés après négociation par
l'Union européenne et moi je trouve que
c'est un exemple
qu'il faudrait suivre peut-être pas pour
tous les médicaments mais pour les
médicaments innovants onéreux ça c'est
une proposition voilà après on peut
encore discuter avec des maladies rares
et abandonner l'industrie on essaie de
mettre en place des structures à but non
lucratives de production de médicaments
au moins dans ce cadre là peut-être un
peu plus mais ça applique un
investissement initial public sans doute
avec l'aide de fondation et du milieu
caritatif peut encore imaginer d'autres
d'autres systèmes en tout état de cause
pour conclure sur ce point de la de
l'accessibilité des médicaments liés à
leur prix
je pense que l'évolution est
indispensable on va dans le mur à terme
pas immédiat mais même si aujourd'hui
les prix sont à peu près l'enveloppe de
prix ne dépense de médicaments en France
et contenu mais les contenus parce qu'on
a créé une nouvelle enveloppe ça c'est
un peu artificiel
je sais plus comment ça s'appelle le nom
de m'échappe mais c'est pas grave le
risque c'est que s'il y a pas une
évolution mais qui implique une
négociation entre le monde public et ind
logiciel pour l'intérêt des deux de mon
point de vue c'est qu'on aille vers une
situation américaine c'est à dire ceux
qui peuvent payer paye et les autres
voilà c'est pas accessible alors tout
dernier point je voudrais évoqué même si
c'est pas mon domaine mais j'ai lu un
peu notamment une référence que je vous
donner si vous l'avez pas parce qu'elle
est très explicite c'est est-ce que tout
ce que je raconte n'est pas une utopie
autrement dit est-ce que la situation
économique de l'industrie fait que c'est
pas possible qui peuvent pas réduire
leur leur prix encore une fois je suis
pas un économiste donc j'avance très
prudemment sur ces questions mais il y a
quand même plusieurs publications qui
montrent que fondamentalement les
bénéfices d'abord un club les bénéfices
du secteur pharmaceutique sont plus
importants que tous les bénéfices de
tous les autres secteurs industriels qui
sont au-dessus j'avais fait un travail à
l'époque avec un économiste belge qui
m'avait montré cela et avec des
références tout à fait ok que par
ailleurs les dépenses j'ai déjà évoqué
mais les il y a une étude récente sur 15
grandes entreprises mondiales les Big
Pharma qui montrent que les dépenses de
marketing
[Musique]
je très très explicite sur les aspects
économiques
voilà je m'arrête là peut-être puis on
continue
merci beaucoup pour ces propos
introductifs déjà très très instructif
et qui pose bien la question je vais
tout de suite passer la parole à Lens
Cohen pour rapporteur pour une liste de
questions
il y a effectivement plusieurs plusieurs
éléments et qui corroborent déjà les les
auditions que nous avons menées parce
que effectivement le prix est quelque
chose qui revient beaucoup mais pas le
prix en fait des médicaments innovants
ça c'est en général c'est pas une grande
part des auditions que nous avons mais
les industriels se plaignent des des
prix trop bas des médicaments matures
voilà donc
on est dans une logique où ils appellent
et LEM
les soutiens là-dessus à évaluer les
prix des médicaments matures or les
exemples que nous avons eu durant nos
auditions c'est que alors que les prix
sont plus élevés en Allemagne ou encore
en Suisse ces pays ont souffert des
pénuries donc ça n'est pas les prix qui
qui sont
qui seraient facteurs de pénurie alors
en même temps il faut passer simplifier
le débat c'est vrai que les pénuries
sont multifactorielles et il y a
plusieurs plusieurs éléments mais voilà
donc c'est important effectivement de
voir comment est-ce qu'on peut arrêter
un peu cette
cette course dans l'évolution des prix
où effectivement il y a une envolée des
prix des prix innovants et avec avec pas
de j'allais dire pas de rendu du service
c'est à dire que quel que soit
finalement les facilités que peuvent
mettre en place les gouvernements c'est
ce que vous avez dit d'une autre façon
il y a pas de retour quoi
par exemple et c'est là-dessus que je
voudrais vous interroger c'est
concernant le cri le crédit impôt
recherche le sien bon à la fois on a eu
dans les dans les auditions le qui nous
a été dit que c'était vraiment
facteur d'attractivité et que on a
entendu ce matin en allant à Bercy que
ça représentait quand même un
investissement extrêmement important
pour l'État français puisque c'est de
l'ordre de 7 milliards à peu près grosso
modo mais en même temps
les mêmes entreprises pour certaines
d'entre elles vont optimiser
pudiquement appelé le crédit impôt
recherche pour échapper
au fait que ils vont devoir produire sur
le marché français et donc pour
rechercher une rentabilité maximale donc
qu'est-ce que vous vous pensez
qu'il serait possible de faire par
exemple est-ce qu'il ne serait pas
important de de mettre un certain nombre
de critères par rapport aux crédits pour
recherche c'est à dire par exemple
vous avez engagé de la une recherche etc
qui a abouti à vous engagez à et vous
avez été en vous avez été aidé en cela
vous vous engagez à une production
française pendant x temps voilà par
exemple ça c'est ma première question de
deuxième question c'est sur la
transparence des prix c'est
effectivement vous avez cité l'OMS c'est
vrai qu'il y a aussi l'Observatoire de
la transparence
des dispositifs des médicaments des
dispositifs médicaux qui demandent à ce
qui est transparence nous nous heurtons
au secret des affaires vous avez donné
un certain nombre d'éléments sur la
transparence qui serait
utile de voir apparaître il pourrait
aussi être utile parmi les critères de
voir apparaître le respect des
de l'environnement et des normes dans
mon environnemental et des normes
sociales et à ce moment là y compris
d'ailleurs peut-être valoriser
les mettre un label en quelque sorte de
souveraineté par rapport aux industriels
qui respectent ces normes
environnementales sociales mais
également de production au niveau du
territoire français ou on peut pas tout
relocaliser mais en tout cas au minimum
européen pour rapprocher donc ça c'est
ma c'est ma deuxième question ma
troisième question vous l'avez un petit
peu abordé où vous avez évoqué l'idée de
la mise en place d'un petit nombre de
structures à but non lucratif afin de
produire des lots de thérapie génique
voir des médicaments au moins des
maladies très rares dont le financement
serait assuré par les États et de
grandes fondations privées telles la
Ligue contre le cancer par exemple
c'était un exemple que vous avez donné
mais il y en aurait d'autres
effectivement nous nous sommes amenés
dans les auditions que que nous que nous
avons faites à réfléchir au fait que au
moins pour une liste de médicaments
courtes
établi mais de manière disons on va dire
les médicaments critiques il y a une
possibilité qu'il y ait une production
publique
et qui se fasse peut-être en lien avec
les pharmacies
hospitalières centrale que ce soit au
niveau de la PHP ou aussi de la PHM etc
etc et qui pourraient bénéficier de
moyens financiers et humains pour
pouvoir le faire alors il s'agit pas
pour nous d'avoir comme idée tout d'un
coup parce qu'elles ont été dépourvues
de leur d'un certain nombre de
d'éléments et notamment en termes de
personnel de produits mais via la
sous-traitance etc elle pourrait
produire
qu'en pensez-vous est-ce que vous pensez
que ça peut être une une solution et la
quatrième enfin quatrième question ça
concerne en fait le pilotage
parce que on a eu l'impression je vais
le dire rapidement pour être clair c'est
que en termes de médicaments il y avait
pas de pilote dans l'avion vraiment et
qu'à un moment donné il y a beaucoup de
d'agences qui font leur travail etc mais
à un moment donné la réponse la le
donneur d'ordre si je puis dire ça doit
être le gouvernement ça doit être le
politique et donc ministère de la Santé
ministère de la Santé par exemple et
enfin la toute dernière question ça
concerne la recherche
puisque vous en avez beaucoup parlé mais
c'est vrai que au niveau de la recherche
il y a une part très importante donc de
recherche avec des financements publics
mais ça n'a pas entraîné une comment
dirais-je un apport privé pour cette
même cette même recherche derrière il y
a un déséquilibre entre le financement
public et le financement privé en termes
de recherche est-ce que ça vous
vous le vous le partagez ou pas et en
tout cas comment est-ce qu'on peut faire
en sorte que ça soit
différent et que quand il y a
investissement en tout cas public comme
c'est le cas il est un retour une espèce
de c'est quand même des quelque part des
missions de service public qui doivent
être redonnés voilà les cinq questions
que je voulais vous poser je vous
remercie moi je rajouterai une c'est
dans votre propos liminaire vous avez
évoqué des thérapies qui ont été
arrêtées par un laboratoire
alors qu'elles avaient un intérêt
thérapeutique un service médical rendu
majeur voilà et donc
est-ce que
d'abord confirmé que le fait qu'elle
soit arrêtée soit un vrai problème pour
la santé publique même s'il y a des
alternatives je pense que la greffe
c'est pas forcément c'est pas exactement
la même chose voilà donc il y a aussi
des effets secondaires voilà différents
et que pensez-vous de l'obligation de
remettre le brevet en ce cas quand le
risque finalement sanitaire est avéré
j'essaye de reprendre dans l'ordre
j'espère que j'ai bien noté crédit impôt
recherche effectivement qui représente
un montant non négligeable de l'un de 7
milliards
ce qui me rend un peu perplexe c'est que
si on regarde les dépenses de recherche
en France elles sont à peu près elle
représente 2,2% du PIB à peu près
c'est un peu moins de 0,8 pour le public
et un peu plus d'un 4 pour le privé si
on regarde en arrière en 2008 on a les
chiffres sont les mêmes en France c'est
à dire que par rapport au PIB la part de
des dépenses de recherche en France n'a
pas progressé donc on est loin de
l'objectif qui avait été fixé dans les
années 90 à la fameuse conférence de
Lisbonne l'Union européenne qui était la
teinte 3%. il est intéressant de se
comparer à l'Allemagne entre autres mais
on peut se qu'on peut à d'autres pays
l'Allemagne était en 2008 environ je
parle de mémoire mais je pense que c'est
juste vous pouvez vérifier facilement
avec le même fraction du PIB consacré à
la recherche et après avec les mêmes
pourcentages publics privés et
aujourd'hui l'Allemagne a dépassé
l'objectif des 3%. et ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que la croissance
publique et privée sont complètement
parallèles donc est-ce que peut dire que
strictement entraîner l'autre il faut
être toujours prudent mais enfin le
constat c'est que le aujourd'hui en
public ils sont 1,1 je sais plus
exactement et en privé donc fait la
différence à neuf c'est que c'est
toujours un rapport 1 à 2 environ mais
mais les deux ont progressé
parallèlement et il y a eu un effort en
gros c'est le mandat de Madame Merkel
mais je crois que c'est possible et
c'est poursuivial la mandature actuelle
de façon très progressive d'augmenter
les crédits de recherche et en le
faisant intelligemment entrer dans les
détails mais ils ont fait des programmes
permettant développer ce que c'est bien
d'avoir des crédits mais il faut bien
les utiliser aussi c'est une évidence et
ils ont fait un magnifique travail et
qui se traduit je pense j'en suis sûr
par recherche qui aujourd'hui a des
performances supérieures à la nôtre mais
peut-être aussi en termes de médicaments
et le covid l'a montré même si je peux
pas établir avec certitude une relation
de cause à effet donc à quoi sert le
crédit impôt recherche en France alors
si je veux avoir une vision un peu
cynique c'est à dire s'il y avait pas le
crédit pour recherche on serait même pas
stable on serait en décroissance je ne
sais pas mais dans tous les cas il n'a
pas permis d'augmenter la part du PIB
privé consacré à la recherche ce qui est
évidemment dommage alors mettre des
critères je pense que
j'aurais assez envie de penser que que
les entreprises qui pourraient le mieux
bénéficier du crédit pour recherche on
les entreprises petites et moyennes qui
sont quand même pas qui n'ont pas les
mêmes situations financières que les Big
Pharma si on reste dans le domaine de la
pharmacie mais cela dit ça s'applique
évidemment à d'autres domaines donc
j'aurais plutôt tendance à je ne sais
pas exactement selon quels critère mais
favoriser l'utilisation de ce crédit un
peu recherche par les entreprises qui ne
sont pas les les très grosses sanofies
mais l'entendre mais aussi je sais pas
Thalès ou d'autres dans des domaines qui
n'ont rien à voir avec la santé par
exemple je suis assez
sensible à ce que vous proposez à l'idée
de mettre des liens en tous les cas des
conditions supplémentaires genre de
nature différente 3 l'emploi des Césars
que ces gens emploie les gens qui ont
fait une thèse de science qui est
toujours un problème en France qui n'est
pas résolu notamment les gens qui ont
des thèses en sciences de la vie avec
une inclusion très inégale et très
insuffisante encore de la thèse dans les
conventions collectives
des clauses ce que je reviens sur la
discute un tout petit peu tout à l'heure
des clauses de prix raisonnables ou de
d'accord
satisfaisant lorsqu'il y a transfert
dans des négociations entre le monde
académique et privé et puis pourquoi pas
une part de production française moi je
dirais européenne pour être plus
réaliste à mon avis ça me choquerait pas
transparence vous avez évoqué les normes
sociales et environnementales ça m'a
fait penser à quelque chose que je
connais pas bien mais dont j'ai entendu
parler qui est pas inintéressant mais
dont j'ai peur que ça soit quand même
pas une solution simple c'est le statut
d'entreprise à mission
qui s'est développée relativement aux
États-Unis prenaient beaucoup une
ex-candidate aux élections
présidentielles américaines Elisabeth
Moron notamment d'ailleurs pour
l'industrie pharmaceutique l'idée étant
pour les c'est ce qui a essayé de faire
comme j'ai oublié
un grand industriel qui a perdu son
poste de PDG Gobain
non non
et j'ai oublié le nom de
quelqu'un qui est très connu mais qui a
perdu il y a deux trois ans son poste de
PDG il a essayé de
transformer Danone en entreprise à
mission donc l'entreprise a mission
c'est une entreprise qui est
indépendamment des des
nécessité de faire des bénéfices et que
les actionnaires soient en soi satisfait
soit satisfait il y a aussi d'autres
objectifs qui sont d'ordre sociaux donc
ça peut être énorme environnementale les
normes sociales ça peut être aussi pour
l'industrie du médicament les prix des
médicaments s'engager à des prix
raisonnables c'est pas une affaire
simple il y a tout
une liste de ditems à remplir il y a
quelques entreprises qui sont au-delà de
Danone qui n'est pas dans le domaine qui
nous concerne directement tous les cas
aujourd'hui bon c'est peut-être une vue
l'esprit parce que est-ce que après tout
ce thème entreprise accepteraient de
modérer leurs prix je ne sais pas mais
ça rentre quand même peut-être un peu
dans la réflexion
bon les questions de transparence par
ailleurs je vais abordé tout à l'heure
et mais c'est évident que toutes les
autres normes doivent intervenir
les productions de médicaments dans des
dans un contexte non lucratif d'avoir
des exemples où ça marche de prendre
deux exemples opposés j'ai oublié le nom
de l'entreprise aux États-Unis mais un
certain nombre de pitos américains ce
sont mis ensemble pour créer une telle
société à but non lucratif qui produit
des médicaments en pénurie ils ont aussi
ce problème comme vous le savez aux
États-Unis j'ai oublié le nom mais ça
existe je sais à peu pas une échelle
très importante mais ça existe et à
l'opposé pour les médicaments très
innovants l'hôpital val-ebronn à
Barcelone développe ses propres cartis
Celtes sur un plan juridique et limite
et mais le prix auquel s'est facturé au
malade donc aux assurances sociales en
Espagne là où c'est 400.000 euros en
France et moins de 100.000 euros en
Espagne
donc on peut y arriver ils ont monté
leur production et une qualité
pharmaceutique indiscutable il s'agit
pas évidemment de transiger d'aucune
façon avec la qualité des médicaments ça
c'est impossible à imaginer une seconde
donc c'est à dire que c'est faisable pas
simple mais c'est faisable donc il y a
effectivement deux axes il y a l'axe des
médicaments courants en pénurie
et l'axe des médicaments innovants le
plus compliqué mais je pense que c'est
pas complètement impossible et on peut
pas avancer massivement dans ces
domaines moi je suis assez favorable à
ce que ces deux axes soient explorés
il faut faire des études économiques sur
les coûts de mise en place etc quels
sont les fondations les vous avez évoqué
la Ligue contre le cancer on pourrait
pour la France on pourrait évoquer l'AFM
qui a des structures qui s'en
rapprochent
il y a je pense que c'est certainement
une piste à explorer qui va pas résoudre
par miracle toutes les problèmes mais
qui pourraient ensemble de questions il
est important de que de montrer en
espérant que ça soit le cas que c'est
ces entreprises sont efficientes
qu'elles ont la qualité qu'elles peuvent
le faire à des prix raisonnables mais si
la preuve de principe est apportée après
on peut avancer un peu plus et donc
mettre peut-être de temps en temps se
mettre en compétition avec l'industrie
et encore les prêtres de brevet c'est
pas complètement ça mais je pense que ce
type de choses à mon avis à nouveau
devait être réfléchi discuté à l'échelle
européenne je pense qu'on partage avec
nos voisins les mêmes problématiques que
ce soit les pénuries de médicaments vous
l'avez évoqué ou la problématique des
prix des médicaments innovants et je
pense que
l'approche rationnelle et la plus
efficiente serait de s'associer de
s'allier avec les Italiens les Allemands
etc et de faire ensemble je pense que ce
serait
plus rentable
quatrième question pilotage de la
politique du médicament qu'est-ce que
vous entendez par le pilotage la
politique vous excluez la recherche à ce
stade là je pense c'est sur le les
stratégies de production les besoins
prioritaires ce genre de choses donc ça
rejoint le capacités de production
S qui souhaitent qui puisse être remises
à disposition à proximité en France ou
en Europe oui effectivement forcément
les pouvoirs publics ont un mot à dire
mais il faut reconnaître que ce sont les
industriels qui produisent ce sont eux
qui ont le savoir-faire et donc ça doit
être une négociation avec eux je pense
que vous en avez beaucoup discuté
j'imagine avec Sanofi et d'autres
bien sûr il faut qu'il y ait une
politique de médicaments est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui
je suis pas capable je connais pas assez
bien des bêtises je suis pas capable
d'apprécier le niveau de perception ou
d'action plus important du ministère de
la Santé en particulier sur cette
question je préfère m'abstenir je
connais pas assez bien regarde bêtises
essayez de pas dire trop de bêtises la
recherche dépense publique déséquilibres
publiques privées alors la réponse est
en fait non il y a pas un déséquilibre
il y a pas assez des deux
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure la
comparaison avec l'Allemagne mais on
pourrait reprendre celle avec les pays
performants en recherche en Europe sans
aller aux États-Unis au Canada en Corée
au Japon sont tous les pays du Nord la
Belgique les Pays-Bas la Grande-Bretagne
la Scandinavie en gros et dans ces pays
là donc il y a des dépenses de recherche
sont globalement supérieurs c'est à
nouveau si on se rapporte au PIB et
elles sont supérieures du côté public et
du côté privé et le ratio c'est assez
intéressant et finalement assez constant
partout il y a des nuances mais vraiment
assez faible à ces chiffres sont
facilement disponibles donc je pense que
ce n'est pas une question déséquilibrée
c'est qu'il y a des montants des crédits
de recherche qui sont insuffisants en
pub dans le domaine public et dans le
domaine privé mais en même temps on
pourrait développer plus longtemps ce
n'est pas qu'une question d'argent c'est
aussi une question d'organisation de
choix stratégique aujourd'hui par
exemple je trouve qu'on met trop
l'accent même s'il faut le faire c'est
important surtout dans toutes les
questions qu'on évoque sur le soutien à
l'innovation à travers le France 2030 et
spécifiquement l'agence d'innovation
santé pour ce qui compte ne concerne le
domaine qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui
mais il n'y a pas assez d'argent vers
l'amant vers la recherche si on veut
innover il faut d'abord trouver ça peut
un peu c'est un tout petit peu primaire
de dire ça mais c'est quand même juste
et je pense que on est un peu trop en
déséquilibre sur ce plan mais donc quand
même quand encore une fois ce n'est pas
qu'un problème public c'est aussi un
problème privé mais j'ai envie de penser
que comme on l'a vu en Allemagne
possiblement l'un peut tirer l'autre
s'il y a une dynamique qui s'instorerait
il faut on a une difficulté en France
c'est que le monde de le même si ça va
mieux que ça a été dans le passé je
crois mais il y a quand même le monde
public et le monde privé sont des mondes
qui ne se connaissent pas assez bien
alors c'est pas le cas dans la plupart
des autres pays pour des raisons à mon
avis qui sont liées à la formation des
gens parce que dans les autres nous
avons une grande spécificité
diversion mais c'est lié au beau sujet
qui concerne le fait nous avons un
système universitaire dual entre les
grandes écoles et les universités et en
gros les dirigeants d'entreprise et les
dirigeants politiques sont viennent d'un
système de grandes écoles avec en
général peu de formation scientifique au
passage et les scientifiques viennent
plutôt l'université plus quelques
grandes écoles spécialisées comme
l'École normale supérieure un tout petit
peu lixe et encore pas tant que ça et si
on demande donc il sépare le 18 ans il
se connaissent plus ça peut paraître je
caricature évidemment mais néanmoins
c'est quand même je pense que ce sont
des mondes qui s'ignorent qui n'ont pas
qui du coup sont défiance relatives
alors que vous allez en Allemagne en
Grande-Bretagne dans ces pays tous ces
gens là ont été dans les mêmes
universités alors pas dans les mêmes
filières mais ils se sont côtoyés ils se
connaissent il se passe des coups de fil
beaucoup plus il se parle beaucoup plus
que que ce qui se passe dans le système
français c'est pas facile d'y remédier
il y a au moins un aspect qu'on peut
faire remarquer c'est que la formation
parle la recherche de des ingénieurs et
beaucoup plus faibles en France qu'en
Allemagne les ingénieurs allemands ont
quatre fois plus souvent que ça géants
français une thèse de sciences c'est pas
dire qu'ils veulent tous faire de la
recherche scientifique mais ça veut dire
qu'ils ont une culture scientifique et
ça va jusqu'au politique Madame Merkel
avait fait de la chimie une thèse de
chimie je pense que ça a joué dans sa
volonté de développer la recherche
pardon je m'arrête sur cette parenthèse
le dernier point
c'est pas simple cette histoire de
d'arrêt de production de produits
innovants alors c'est vrai que c'est la
société orchard qui a une petite société
britannique qui avait développé qui a
racheté ses produits etc et finalement
comme elle a un médicament pour une
autre maladie qui où il y a là c'est il
y a pas d'alternative du tout et qu'il
vendent deux fois plus cher pour ce
qu'on appelle une moque mucopolis
acharidose humanise surcharge ils ont
choisi de développer cette thérapie là
beaucoup plus
rentable que les défiscitaires là c'est
vrai qu'il y a une petite perte en
charge honnêtement aujourd'hui parce
qu'il y a eu des progrès des grèves de
moelle osseuse c'est moins je veux là il
y a 10 ans je vous aurais dit c'est une
catastrophe aujourd'hui je dis que c'est
moins grave effectivement se pose la
question parce qu'on peut on peut
l'extrapoler à d'autres domaines
qu'est-ce qui se passe ici un produit
n'est plus développé alors qu'il a un
intérêt médical indiscutable je pense
que c'est des situations on peut
imaginer d'intervenir pour faire en
sorte que c'est ce produit puisse être
produit y compris dans les structures
non lucratif pourquoi pas le racheter
les la des prix raisonnables les droits
sur ces produits c'est éventuellement
envisageable pas simple mais peut pas
être fait à grande échelle mais au cas
par cas c'est pareil
ce que vous souhaitez apporter des
éléments complémentaires
j'ai rien à dire de qu'il soit
intéressant pour vous parce que je
connais pas assez bien cette histoire
des brevets est un vrai sujet parce que
on voit bien que la stratégie des grands
laboratoires et quand même finalement
ou de trouver quelqu'un d'autre pour
fabriquer des produits matures ou
d'arrêter tout court en tout cas c'est
une espèce de logique qu'on voit se
dessiner et les pays dans la les
facteurs des pénuries on voit bien que
c'est
cette
responsabilité là est importante
je pense qu'il faut quand même vraiment
distinguer la situation des médicaments
médicament courant qui coûte pas très
cher des médicaments innovants c'est
vraiment de évidemment c'est
complètement connecté puisqu'on est même
producteurs
mais en termes de démarche
sont quand même de deux situations assez
différentes
conscient de cela
non en fait on a abordé les ce sujet
vous avez bien compris parce que les
deux sont liés et qu'il y a des
stratégies industrielles et qu'on voit
bien que voilà les choses manifestement
sont partis vers un effet de ciseaux de
plus en plus crucial dans les choses
réalistes de tout ce que je dis je sais
pas tout ce que j'ai dit est loin d'être
réaliste à mon avis malheureusement
j'aimerais bien que ça la soit il y en a
une à mon avis enfin si je me permets
sur lequel je voudrais insister que pour
beaucoup pour plusieurs des sujets
évoqués c'est l'Union européenne je suis
convaincu que quand même Union
européenne c'est un énorme part du
marché du médicament même si les
États-Unis etc je répète pas ce que j'ai
dit mais quand même c'est un gros
morceau
ça représente une force de recherche
économique politique importante et je
pense que agir sur toutes ces questions
à l'échelle de l'Europe que ce soit sur
les pénuries sur les médicaments
innovants une certaine façon sur la
recherche je pense que l'Union
européenne ferait beaucoup mieux que
chacun des pays c'est vraiment un
domaine où l'Union européenne peut à une
valeur ajoutée à mon avis considérable
mais bon c'est mon point de vue
la question du même s'il est moins
régulé qu'en France le prix du
médicament des pénuries sont présentes
également et puis il y a aussi pour
régler des questions d'accès qui
rapportent de l'argent
et on voit bien qu'il y a eu un souci de
aussi
pour des raisons de l'accessibilité pour
l'insuline par exemple il y a eu une
tentative de régulation du prix de
l'insuline est vendu à des prix
exorbitance exorbitant
donc on est face à une pathologie qui
est quand même relativement fréquente
mais on s'aperçoit par exemple hier on a
on a on a auditionné un membre de la
fiou Cruz au Brésil et on s'est aperçu
dans la façon dont il nous a
décrit la situation alors Brésil pays
continent 220 millions d'habitants on
n'est pas sur la même échelle mais
continue de ce qu'ils ont fait par
rapport au VIH et de la présence de la
fille aux Cruz la fiou Cruz elle est
capable de faire de la recherche
de produire des médicaments et de les
distribuer donc à partir de ce moment là
elle a quand même un pouvoir de réaction
et d'action extrêmement considérable
alors que ce que ce qu'on s'est dit
depuis le début ensemble c'est que le
gouvernement français mais pas que le
gouvernement français mais pour ce qui
nous intéresse et quand même tributaire
des décisions qui vont prendre
les industriels et c'est ça c'est pour
ça que je j'ai remis un peu dans la
course les parce que je ne vois pas
d'autres d'autres possibilités les
pharmacies centrales au niveau
hospitalier parce que elles peuvent
éventuellement mais elles ont été
beaucoup des armées il y a du boulot
quand même voilà mais oui c'est une
toute petite base mais parce qu'il faut
il faut il faut partir de quelque chose
mais comme il y a pas la volonté moi je
vois bien entre le moment on est en 2023
et le moment où je suis je suis élue en
2011 je vois tous les moyens que la GEP
par exemple a perdu elle est plus en
capacité de produire aujourd'hui elle
passe par la sous-traitance par d'autres
voilà donc si vous voulez au fur et à
mesure quand on se donne pas les moyens
on les a pas
si je peux un petit commentaire sur le
Brésil et l'Inde aussi sont des pays qui
en est des structures de production
médicament ou de vaccin par ailleurs
mais c'est un médicament aussi
de très performant et ça leur permet
pour des médicaments courants et des
médicaments pour lesquels
les brevets sont tombés etc etc d'avoir
accès à des prix raisonnables à des
médicaments restent que ils ont le même
problème avec les médicaments innovants
la recherche brésilienne n'est pas telle
elle n'est pas dans les malheureusement
pour eux les médicaments innovants
aujourd'hui ils viennent pas du Brésil
ils viennent les États-Unis ils viennent
un peu l'Europe mais bon donc ça permet
d'assurer typiquement les médicaments du
VIH qui est hyper important évidemment
ou un certain nombre d'agents
anti-infectueux dont ils ont besoin etc
mais c'est il y a quand même une limite
aussi c'est c'est
juste préciser ça
ils ont l'intelligence de développer des
coopérations avec la France avec
l'Institut Pasteur avec un certain
nombre donc il ils sont quand même dans
une démarche qui peut aboutir et donc et
comme ils ont les outils après pour pour
développer ils ont quand même réussi par
exemple par rapport à la force leur
marché à récupérer toute la ça s'appelle
pas
la technologie derrière un messager et
de pouvoir c'est quand même excusez-moi
mais là je dirais avoir
ils ont ils ont produit massivement et
c'est très bien le vaccin d'AstraZeneca
etc mais après ce qu'ils peuvent
développer par eux-mêmes ensuite
d'autres choses sortir du Sark of 2 et
transposer une autre maladie infectieuse
je pense qu'ils n'ont pas cette
technologie aujourd'hui malheureusement
pour eux s'ils peuvent effectivement
produire ils savent très bien produire
en masse ce qui est bien l'Inde aussi
cette capacité
l'Egypte je sais pas oui c'est peut-être
je sais pas encore OK
merci beaucoup je vous en prie pour cet
échange très instructif